the attorney for one of a Leslie Moonves
accuser says her client will speak out
today with two independent law firms
investigating sexual misconduct claims
against the former CBS chairman and CEO
moonves's you know was forced to resign
on Sunday afternoon you Sal agay shion's
by seven women were published a
separation agreement shows that Moonves
could collect 120 million dollar
severance payment if the independent
investigation finds that CBS had no
grounds to remove him Jericka Duncan has
a closer look at that deal and joins us
at the tables Rico good morning good
morning to you Gail Moonves for now will
remain on unpaid advisor to CBS with a
company provided office in New York or
Los Angeles along with home security
services we may never know exactly what
CBS is able to discover about his
behavior in his separation agreement the
company agreed to keep the investigation
into the allegations confidential
victims advocates are pushing the
network for transparency Leslie Moonves
his wife Julie Chen was noticeably
absent from the season premiere of her
CBS show the top
she says she's taking a few days off to
be with her family as you will know
Judy's husband is in the news co-host
Sharon Osbourne previously went on
Twitter saying the allegations were an
attempt to discredit Leslie
a spokesperson for Osborne tells CBS
News Chen had asked her to make a
statement in support of Moonves she
walked back those remarks on yesterday's
show it's not being convicted of any
crime but obviously the man has a
problem The New Yorker in Vanity Fair
reported seven new allegations of sexual
assault and harassment against Moonves I
never expect something like this
longtime television executive Phyllis
golden Gottlieb spoke to us with her
lawyer Gloria Allred Goldin Gottlieb
filed a complaint last year with Los
Angeles police reporting Moonves
assaulted her back in 1986 he grabbed my
head and grabbed it and pushed it down
onto his penis prosecutors declined to
file charges saying the statutes of
limitations had expired CBS has now
hired two independent law firms to
investigate
allegations against Moonves I would urge
the board to make any report that they
receive from these independent
investigators public in a statement
Moonves wrote he's deeply saddened to be
leaving CBS saying untrue allegations
from decades ago are now being made
against me that are not consistent with
who I am and regulatory filings CBS
reported it was putting 120 million
dollars into a trust the money will go
to Moonves only if the investigation
finds he cannot be terminated for cause
the company says it's also donating 20
million dollars to organizations that
support the me2 movement and equality
for women in the workplace it's a drop
in the bucket when you compare it to les
moonves's salary over the last few years
fatima Goss graves runs the National
Women's Law Center and is a leader of
the times up movement she's calling on
CBS to be open with the investigation
CBS has an opportunity to show us
dramatically either how to do the right
thing or how to do the wrong thing
that's why people are watching so
closely in this moment the independent
investigation is also looking at the
culture here within CBS News it's been
nearly 10 months since the company fired
Charlie Rose over reports of sexual
harassment and 60 minutes executive
producer Jeffrey Hager has denied
allegations of inappropriate behavior
and of tolerating misconduct obviously
as you mentioned yesterday a tough story
I think as far as not just reckoning
people want results and part of that is
this report which of course they're
advocating for transparency but we're
not even sure exactly when that report
will you know I am so sorry again that
it's so close to home for us
you know I'm sick and sick of the story
and sickened by everything that we keep
hearing but the part you mentioned about
transparency is very disturbing to me
because I would think how can we have
this investigation and not know how it
comes out les Moonves has been on the
record he says listen he didn't do these
things that it was consensual that he
hasn't hurt anybody's career and I would
think it would be in his best interest
for us to hear what the report finds out
on the other hand you have women who are
coming forward very credibly talking
about something that's so painful and so
humiliating
it's been my experience that women don't
come out and speak this way for no
reason they just don't they just don't
do it and so I don't know how we move
forward if we don't we at CBS don't have
full transparency about what we find
John you know I wasn't here yesterday
because I was in a wedding in Europe as
you guys know but I thought it was
interesting when you said a friend of
yours said for 30 years this has haunted
her because we of course we're talking
about it all weekend and someone said
what how does anybody remember what
happened 30 years ago when it is that
traumatic and that humiliating you
remember every single detail like it had
happened yes it's not just it's not just
in the moment it's when you go to the
lawyer and the lawyer says it's your
word against exactly against his that
sense of powerlessness lives with you
for a long our own house we must have
transparency and I certainly feel for
Julie Chen today you know she's in a
very difficult position and you know les
Moonves has done some wonderful things
for this company and we can't forget
that either so it's just a bad situation
all the way around but I'm glad that we
are covering the story it's important
that we cover it and get to the bottom
of wherever it whatever it is right
you're right down but you know thank you
tarika Matt how was your day see you
Thanks